immer mehr senioren leben im heim
und wer noch eigene vier wände hat und
oft allein das traditionelle drei
generationen haus gibt's was nicht mehr
ich bin einsam im haus kenne ich
niemanden als du denn die meisten kinder
kennen kaum jemanden über 80 wie könnten
diese generationen wieder zusammenfinden
[Musik]
es hat so etwas magisches auch
entsprechende format ischen momenten
wenn jung und alt zusammen treffen da
kam einiges geschehen
das sag ich immer klingberg danke
[Musik]
morgens in waldkirch an der
kindertagesstätte pfiffikus ein rollator
sagt fluss du kennst das ist viele
bremen vier jahre alt und was machst du
es mal probieren
philipp und seine freunde bereiten sich
auf einen besonderen ausflug vor ein
wissenschaftliches projekt der
evangelischen hochschule freiburg
untersucht ob hochbetagte und
vorschulkinder voneinander profitieren
können
und wenn wie man es am besten
organisiert mit leidenschaft dabei
erzieherin barbara weiss
[Musik]
ich bin ein großer verfechter von
erfahrungen zusammen
ich glaube meine kind was der kreis dann
begreift dass auch mensch dann nicht
mehr gehen kann da handicap set das da
trotzdem noch teilhaben kann an viele
dinge in denen sehr glücklicher weise
diese hilfsmittel gibt das möchte ich
die kinder vermieden die anderen
projektteilnehmer leben im seniorenstift
st nicolai auch die 92 jährige margarita
wandel seit knapp zwei jahren ist sie
hier daheim schlafe ich mein
schlafzimmer und bildung und mond zimmer
alles hinein
frau wagner ist seit vielen jahren witwe
19 jahre ist schon tot und 48 war ich
verheiratet und zig salomons vorherrsche
kind sie hat zwei kinder und vier enkel
die können nicht jeden tag kommen frau
wanda strikt und denkt an frühe lese
kann ich eine gut willicher auge leider
habt der grüne star aber das ist auch
immer altersbedingt ich wäre
93 aber mehr hinterher kurz nach der
verstand gelassen ich kann noch'
zurückdenke ballbesitz die kinder gaben
[Musik]
nein
die freiburger wissenschaftler prüfen
seit sieben jahren was es mit kindern
und senioren macht wenn sie regelmäßig
kontakt miteinander haben
[Musik]
pädagogin dörte weltzien betreut das
projekt
es gibt hatte ich gar keine evolution es
gibt keine wissenschaftlichen beweise
dafür dass es wirklich positive
auswirkungen hat und wir sind mit einer
ganz offenen fragen stellung
reingegangen hinaus wird kann man sich
ja vorstellen das wir ist dass die
kinder hier erleben auch befremdlich ist
also dass sie neue gerüche kennenlernen
die sie nicht kennen das dass bestimmte
dinge sie irritieren oder auch verärgern
oder vielleicht sogar uns machen und all
das muss man ja wenn man
wissenschaftlich unterwegs ist auch mit
berücksichtigen
ganz wichtig für die wissenschaftler
sind regelmäßige begegnungen zwischen
möglichst den gleichen teilnehmen um
veränderungen zu beobachten und zu
analysieren
wer verändert sich und warum erklärt es
ist uns warum es in halle eingeladen und
eine dame der besuch dauert insgesamt
nur eine stunde
das ist wichtig denn die
konzentrationsfähigkeit beider seiten
ist kurz ich mich sehr gut dosiert sein
das merkt man auch an diesen begegnungen
es darf nicht zu lang sein das muss an
einem zeitpunkt am tag sein was passt
das muss sehr sehr gut begleitet seien
sehr gut vorbereitet
ein sehr gut gestaltet sein das ist das
was zählt die treffen sehen alltäglich
aus doch alles ist genau geplant für
aussagekräftige ergebnisse muss der
ablauf immer ähnlich sein und gefilmt
also dokumentiert werden gerontologe
thomas klie analysiert vor allem gefühls
ausdrücke und die älteren den ist
dornröschen bekannt das hat eine in der
regel biografische verankerung und die
aktualisieren genau das was sie mit
diesen märchengeschichten mit den
märchen spielen verbinden und erleben
das jetzt mit den kindern das ist sehr
belebend für sie und schafft auch so
eine art von innerer kontinuität ein
kontinuität erleben aber sie das sieht
man auch sehr schön in diesen sequenzen
sie sind sehr lebendig und sind in
beziehung zu den kindern jetzt staunen
beide es hat so etwas magisches auch wir
sprechen den opfern magischen momenten
die da entstehen sind es nur kleine
besondere momente wie alltagstauglich
ist das experiment
[Musik]
in wien ist das organisierte miteinander
von alt und jung längst aus dem
experimentierstadium heraus in diesen
pensionisten haus sind gleich zwei
kindergärten des vereins kinderfreunde
untergebracht die begegnung mit senioren
ist für diese kinder etwas
selbstverständliches heute nehme ich bin
felix mit gitarre daniel nicht nur die
kinder freuen sich manche der senioren
warten geradezu darauf im treppenhaus
den kindern zu begegnen und hände zu
schütteln
[Musik]
jung und alt in einem haus das wird noch
nicht häufig gemacht doch das prinzip
hat zukunft
die seniorinnen und senioren hier leben
in wohngruppen einige sind dement einige
bettlägerig nur wenige sind vollkommen
gesund aber auf die treffen mit den
kindern freuen sich alle
einmal pro woche gibt es gemeinsame
aktionen heute wird gemacht
wichtig ist dass jeder der will auch
mitmachen kann sport und herumtoben
fallen also flach das schöne ist dass
sie sich dann schon kennen das sie dann
schon freundschaften entwickeln dass sie
dann schon wie es nach der wahl letztes
mal da oder sie kommen und sagen ich
habe das von dir aufgehängt das hängt in
meiner wohnung ja und die kinder freuen
sich dann natürlich weil sie wissen ich
werde geschätzt
die betreuer achten sehr darauf dass
grenzen gewahrt sind berührt
gestreichelt zu werden das mögen vor
allem die kinder oft nicht
also das ist doch diese arbeit finde ich
so eine schöne arbeit auf mit dem pinsel
weil auch der direkte hautkontakt durch
den pinsel vermieden wir wir versuchen
einen aufgang zu finden wo schon noch
nähe ist aber doch nicht vielleicht zu
viel körperliche nähe wo vielleicht auch
viele kinder dann vielleicht ein
bisschen sich zurückziehen werden emily
mag nicht mehr
das klar zu zeigen ist auch etwas das
die kinder bei den begegnungen werden
geschäftsführerin gabriele graumann und
ihr team arbeiten für dieses besondere
miteinander das konfliktsituationen aber
ausdrücklich zahl ist
es geht hier nicht um ein walt disney
oder in diesem land verhalte sondern es
geht einfach hier darum das leben und
das leben besteht aus alten und jungen
dicken und dünnen unterschiedlichen
lebensentwürfen und so weiter und so
fort
eben auch in diesem in diesem haus hin
zu einem haus rein zu lassen und schauen
was passiert
das wahre leben rein lassen das
praktizieren sie auch im obergeschoss
des heims hier leben mehr als hundert
asylbewerber davon 30 kinder eine der
bewohnerinnen ist eva lutz meier 65
jahre alt sie sitzt wegen einer
muskelschwäche im rollstuhl
das hindert sie aber nicht daran für die
flüchtlingskinder da zu sein und
umgekehrt
mein leben ohne den kindern wer sehr
sinnlos
ich habe eine aufgabe gefunden und das
gibt mir viel kraft
eigentlich ist es zeit für judt meyers
mittagsschlaf doch gerade jetzt brauchen
die kinder sie
in waldkirch lebt der vierjährige
philipp zusammen mit seinen eltern und
seinem bruder elias seine großeltern
wohnen noch in den eigenen vier wänden
und haben regelmäßig kontakt zu dem
enkel philipp besucht als eines von
sechs kindergartenkindern jede woche die
hochbetagten senioren im pflegeheim
die wissenschaftler wollen heute sehen
wie und was lernen alt und jung
voneinander
dafür haben sie ein gemeinsames suppen
kochen inszeniert der tisch muss noch
gewischt werden
das kann philipp für die seniorinnen
übernehmen gekocht hat er vorher noch
nie da kommen die damen als expertinnen
ins spiel
jetzt probierst du die kinder merken
schnell die alten sind zwar langsam
können aber vieles trotzdem besser sie
haben einen erfahrungsschatz von dem die
kinder lernen
erzeugt möglichkeiten der nähe
aufzubauen und zwar eine lange
unverbindlichen er das weil man einfach
zusammen sitzt und sich da eine möhre
teilt die man irgendwie fehlen muss und
so ist es geht es dem philipp dass er
das offensichtlich noch nicht so oft
gemacht hat wie die alten damen ihnen
gegenüber und er sehr fasziniert davon
ist also wie sie das schnibbeln und das
versucht auch zu machen merkt wie
schwierig das ist ja wie stark man sein
muss
und das sind auch momente wo er das hohe
alter was er vielleicht in anderer form
sonst wo erlebt hat auf einmal auf eine
neue art und weise kennen lernt alltags
momente alltags dialoge genau das wollen
die wissenschaftler einfangen und daraus
lernen
die seniorin maria theresia ebene wirkt
in solchen situationen entspannt und vor
allem geistig völlig klar
tatsächlich ist sie schwer dement
[Musik]
spielt im mittelpunkt aber mehr geräte
mit haben sie noch was anderes gemacht
außer gespielt
das gemeinsame lachen das kochen
der kleine philipp alles weg wertvoll
war die erfahrung trotzdem
menschen mit demenz leben in der regel
im augenblick und glück ist denn ein
moment des augenblicks das gucken wir
auch an wenn wir die videosequenzen
analysieren und das verfliegt und das
ist bei kindern ja auch häufig so und
wenn wir ehrlich sind
das glück ist immer flüchtig aber ein
teil der gesellschaft zu sein das wirkt
nachhaltig die forscher sind sich
auch wenn die monotonie des alltags nur
kurz unterbrochen wird
schon diese ersten treffen verändern das
lebensgefühl
[Musik]
mehr als 90 prozent der senioren in
deutschland liegen nicht im heim sondern
in den eigenen vier wänden
je älter desto einsamer das gilt
besonders für frauen
hilde klein und ihr mann zogen vor 15
jahren wegen der kultur in die
wagnerstadt bayreuth
doch vor wenigen jahren starb er nun ist
sie über 90 und ganz allein
ich bin einsam ich sind in bayreuth habe
ich kein anfang anhang gefunden
ich habe mich bemüht habe einiges
unternommen habe auf inserate
geschrieben aber nichts sonst im haus
kenne ich niemand alle studenten die
sagen ja nicht mal guten tag oder was
also da bin ich einsam
doch in bayreuth gibt es vom freistaat
bayern geförderte hilfe yvette malich
ist 16 jahre alt und mitglied im verein
jung und alt zusammen kurz platz
[Musik]
also ich helfe generell sehr gerne
anderen leuten und wenn man anderen
leuten helfen kann dass es noch mal so
noch mehr sozialer würde ich jetzt mal
sagen vereins mit gründerin monika
helgert wie die schülerin frau klein
vorstellen denn die sucht eine
einkaufshilfe
[Musik]
die welt wird heute mit ihnen einkaufen
gehen ja ein sehr schön freue ich mich
nach gut also hoffentlich finden wir
dass alles was wir brauchen ich habe
einen zettel gemacht einkaufen kann
hilde klein zwar noch aber sie fühlt
sich zunehmend unsicher und kann schwere
ware wie getränkekästen nicht mehr heben
hier kann ihr wird wertvolle hilfe
bieten und sie hat die zeit dafür
monika helgert geht beim ersten mal noch
mit schaut wie yvette und frau klein
miteinander zurechtkommen vor helgert
arbeitet ehrenamtlich
[Musik]
mein persönliches motiv ist weil ich
einfach auch der menschen hilft und weil
ich die freude der menschen und die
dankbarkeit spüren
die sind alle so glücklich dass sie
endlich jemand haben auf den sie sich
verlassen können dass die einsamkeit
damit muss so schlimm
noch hat hilde klein nicht entschieden
ob sie und yvette wirklich
zusammenpassen
der verein yards ist erst wenige monate
alt aber schon gut nachgefragt drei
ehrenamtliche teilen sich ein witziges
buch
wir haben über 300 mitglieder und zwei
drittel davon bieten hilfe an und ein
drittel braucht aktuell hilfe und von
daher nicht so leicht es jemanden zu
finden auch wenn es spontan schnell
gehen muss die welt kann sich aussuchen
wie sie entlohnt werden will
entweder acht euro pro stunde abzüglich
zwei euro für den verein oder sie
bekommt eine gegenleistung wie etwa
kochunterricht von einem der senioren
oder sie spart ihr stunden guthaben für
später wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise
auch älter bin und probleme mit
gartenarbeit hab zum beispiel ist und es
dann wieder jüngere leute gibt die sich
dafür anbieten würden würde ich das hat
dann kostenlos bekommen
frau klein ist zufrieden es hat ab
sofort ihr volles vertrauen
monika hellgardt ist schon wieder
unterwegs
eine interessentin hat sich gemeldet und
hat noch fragen
viele ältere haben zum beispiel bedenken
fremde schüler ins haus zu lassen
in waldkirch besuchen seniorinnen und
kindergartenkinder ein museum auch hier
jedes detail genauestens geplant von den
forschern beim gemeinsamen fußweg lernen
die kinder dass man auch im rollstuhl
noch mobil ist der vierjährige philipp
hatte die idee für die seniorinnen etwas
zu basteln
ihr habt einen zu schenken viele studios
hängen der formal ja wunderschön
gemeinsam gehen die beiden auf
entdeckungstour dankeschön
sie lassen sich aufeinander ein man
sieht das ja sehr schön nicht entsteht
sogar ein bisschen zärtlichkeit im blick
oder auch in einer bewegung und die kann
ich akzeptieren wenn mich jemand berührt
den ich überhaupt nicht kenne die nicht
wirklich irgendwie auch ganz merkwürdig
finde es schrecklich zurück die
93-jährige margareta wandler und der
vierjährige philipp haben eine
gemeinsame leidenschaft entdeckt die
alemannische fastnacht philipp kennt
viele kostüme und masken und frau
wangler noch sämtliche bräuche aus ihrer
kindheit weitere anknüpfungspunkte
künftige gespräche
schön hell dass simon rouse jawohl
fischstücke philipp und frau wanda haben
sich an diesem nachmittag für gemeinsame
zeit getrennt von der gruppe entschieden
ein erstes zeichen dass ihre bindung
enger wird im wiener pensionisten haus
ist mittagszeit bewohnerinnen eva uta
übt mit den flüchtlingskindern lesen und
schreiben
die kinder leben mit ihren familien im
oberen schuss es sind über 100 menschen
die noch nicht wissen ob sie als
flüchtlinge anerkannt werden
einige mütter helfen in der wäscherei
des hauses um die kinderbetreuung müssen
sie sich keine sorgen machen
dafür ist unter anderem eva roth meyer
da die flüchtlingskinder können sich im
haus recht frei bewegen
meist treffen sie sich mit ihrer user im
café
lärm und kartenspielen nicht jeder
bewohner findet das gut
danke sie merken ja wir sind nicht sehr
leise und da gibt es keine probleme
ich will es nicht verschweigen arbeit
manche kinder vermissen ihre
großfamilien daher an eva roth meyer
schätzen sie vor allem ihre unendliche
geduld ist ein bisschen eine großmutter
wirklich wenn sie kommen und mich
umarmen und links und rechts am busse
geben
sie ist online das sag ich immer kinder
danke
[Musik]
alt und jung fremd und venere hier
funktioniert es ganz selbstverständlich
[Musik]
in der nähe von bayreuth wohnt der 17
jährige julius spätling er ist schüler
und möchte sich zum taschengeld etwas
dazuverdienen
der verein jung und alt zusammen kurz
was hat ihm einen job vermittelt
gartenarbeit julius soll erst mal zur
probe arbeiten ein senioren ehepaar lebt
in einem zu groß gewordenen haus die
kinder sind schon lange ausgezogen
in bayern gibt es inzwischen schon 16
vereine wie das jetzt in zukunft sollen
gesammelte blut haben auch zwischen den
städten austauschbar werden wer etwa in
kronach oder berchtesgaden arbeitet
könnte dann zum beispiel in bayreuth
statt bargeld garten arbeitsstunden
abrufen
der große garten der nach wohlstand
aussieht wird für familie man mehr und
mehr zur last
marianne und ihr kranker mann folgt mal
können sich einen professionellen
gärtner nicht mehr leisten
die acht euro stundenlohn zu julius
gerade noch ein finanzielles argument
ja ich das erklären was erklärt man
nicht so gerne
also weil man zahlt knapp 800 euro
krankenkasse und ist ein großer teil was
von der rente nicht geht dann bleibt da
nicht mehr viel übrig und ich selbst
habe auch eine rente nur von etwas unter
500 euro
also da muss man schon sehr rechnen
julius weiß dass senioren hilfe aber
auch gesellschaften
ich mach das jetzt nicht bloß weil ich
mir neue sachen zu kaufen sondern ich
denke auch dass das viel
zwischenmenschliches ist was dann
entstehen kann wenn man einfach auf in
anführungsstrichen gesetz freundlicher
und freundschaftlicher basis da eben
älteren leuten hilft den garten oder das
haus klar zu machen
monika helgert erklärt inzwischen der
83-jährigen interessentin helga kastner
die hilfsmöglichkeiten des vereins frau
kastner lebt zwar noch ganz gut allein
will aber vor sorgen
[Musik]
was hätten sie denn für tierbedarf was
könnte der verein für sie tun also im
moment bin ich ja noch aber wenn es mal
beim erstmal so wäre was man auf jeden
fall im haus waldberg und was machen
fensterputzen ja jetzt machen
derzeit leisten die vereins mitglieder
im monat etwa 150 hilfs stunden und es
werden immer mehr
marianne und volkmann haben sich
entschieden sie möchten julius gerne
öfter engagieren
bei einem glas tee wollen sie besprechen
wie oft julius kommen und welche
arbeiten er genau übernehmen soll
[Musik]
sechs wochen nach dem kennenlernen
zwischen jung und alt sind in waldkirch
zarte freundschaften entstanden ein
bisschen zwischen oma und nachbarskind
manche der dementen teilnehmerinnen
erinnern sich gar nicht an die kinder
doch mal geräte wangler freut sich auf
ihren liebling mitgebracht
[Musik]
die forscher haben eine weitere
vertrauensbildende aktion vorbereitet
die kinder und seniorinnen sollen
gemeinsam mal das ist allen vertraut und
soll bei den einen die neugier und bei
den anderen die erinnerungen rechnung
[Musik]
schau mal ich hab dir aufs mitgebracht
da spricht einer uci alles wegnehmen
ja natürlich ich hab's dir mitgebracht
du hast mir ja auch ist so schöne stein
gemacht denn habe ich auf nachtisch geld
in den gemeinsamen momenten vergessen
die alten ihre einschränkungen und die
jungen dass sie eigentlich herumtoben
wollen die jungen werden ruhig und die
seniorinnen wie der mutter
erzieherin barbara weiss beobachtet wie
sich die teilnehmer in den vergangenen
wochen verändert haben
[Musik]
es gibt oft das bestimmen die kinder
bestimmte beziehungen zu menschen
schließen dass sowas passiert dass es
sich irgendwie nahe stehen
und ich finde es auch ganz schön wie sie
sich gegenseitig erzählen
das ist heute viele wichtige und
bereichern und die frau schwanger werde
viel lebendiger ins erzählt wie wenig
sie sonst erleben sie blieben lange oben
sitzen und warten den zipfelmützen
er kam der große brüste wind und pustet
alles um geschwind also die kinder die
in weile an solchen begegnung
teilgenommen haben die haben ein ganz
anderes wissen ganz anderen zugang zur
lebenswelt in dem hohen alter die können
uns in den interviews sehr viel
berichten was alte menschen können was
sie denken was sie beschäftigt und was
sie vielleicht auch nicht können und sie
haben sehr differenziertes positives
positiv geprägtes bild vom alter was
aber realistisch ist
insgesamt haben die wissenschaftler
festgestellt dass bei regelmäßigen
treffen beide jung und alt enorm dazu
lernen die kinder erfahren dass alte
menschen eben mehr sind als einfach nur
alt und entdecken ihre fähigkeiten im
umgang mit ihnen die senioren erleben
dass sie immer noch viel zu geben haben
und gewinnen lebensqualität also unsere
ausgangssperre wurde deutlich bestätigt
dass ältere menschen in der regel
mäßigen begegnung mit kindern mit
vorschulkindern sehr viel emotionale
qualität erfahren was sie stärkt und
diese begegnungen geben älteren menschen
auch das gefühl von bedeutung und in der
welt sein
jeder hat seine kompetenzen und altern
ist eine gestaltungsaufgabe
und das altern des bund
auch wenn die jüngsten und die ältesten
unsere gesellschaft heute meist nicht
mehr zusammenleben regelmäßige
begegnungen können sie einander wieder
näher bringen
begegnungen bei denen jeder einzelne und
die gesellschaft gewinnt
[Musik]
ja